[SPEAKING HEBREW]
BETTY SAADEH: My
name is Betty Saadeh.
I'm one of members
of the Speed Sisters.
Speed Sisters were the
first female racing
team in Palestine.
For a woman in a very
reserved society,
instead of just staying
home, and getting
married, and taking
care of their kids,
to find them between
men, and racing,
and drifting, not real easy.
NOOR DAOUD: When
I started racing,
nobody really respected me.
It was weird.
But it was like, why
don't you just be at home,
and get married, and I can do
something good in your life.
BETTY SAADEH: This
is the only thing
I can have fun and
feel free is racing.
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
MONA ENAB: We don't
have a special track
for the races in Palestine.
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
MONA ENAB: We have like five
races we do it the year,
and in Palestine,
and three races
will be outside of Palestine.
There is me and more girls
are racing with the boys.
There's a lot of boys
in racing here today.
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
BETTY SAADEH: Oh, this is the
only big parking lot we have.
See, it's full of rocks.
This little boy was
shot and killed,
so all his classmates
come here and throw rocks
at the Israeli's soldiers.
So one day, I came with
[? Noud ?] to practice,
and they started
shooting at me tear gas.
I got shot two in the back.
And since that day,
I don't come here.
NOOR DAOUD: Of course, it's
also hard in Palestine,
because we're under occupation.
And we have to pass
checkpoints, and you
have to go through
things, and it's not
easy to live in Palestine.
So I'm sure like, yes, I
mean, racing helps a lot
to get the frustration out.
BETTY SAADEH: I think
we, the Speed Sisters, we
changed the picture
of Palestinian women.
We want to do our lives, and
do our hobbies, and have fun.
Woo.
NOOR DAOUD: A lot
of people, they
come to me, like they want to
learn, especially little girls.
And I like that, and I'm
willing to help anybody
that wants to go for it.
NOOR DAOUD: I want
to see people to show
their [? tone ?] to the world.
So that's why, one
day, I hope I will
open an academy in Palestine,
and bring all the people that
wants to learn, and teach them,
and just live their dreams.
To see another group of
daredevil all-starts,
check out Parkour Boys of Kabul.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
And if you want to see Seeker
episodes three days early,
then check out Vessel.
Vessel allows you to watch
exclusive early access videos
before the rest of the instant.
Click the link in the
description for your free 30
day trial.